[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: One
of the best things
about writing applications using
Android's Runtime is that it's
a managed memory environment,
which means you don't have
to worry about all the extra
overhead of when objects are
created and destroyed.
But be careful here.
Even in a managed
memory language,
you can still end
up leaking memory.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And memory leaks are a common
issue in complex code bases.
And if not handled
properly, can easily
lead to some nasty performance
problems in your apps.
As you might recall, memory
heaps in Android's Runtime
are segmented into spaces
based on the type of allocation
and how the system can best
organize those allocations
for future GC events.
As new objects are allocated,
these characteristics
are taken into
account to best fit
what space it should
be placed into,
depending on what version
of Android's Runtime
you are using.
And here's the important part.
Each space has a set size.
Now, as objects
are allocated, we
keep track of the
combined sizes.
And as the space starts
to grow, the system
will need to execute
a garbage collection
event in an attempt to free up
memory for future allocations.
These GC events aren't
generally a noticeable problem
for performance.
However, a lot of them,
occurring over and over
and over and over again, can
quickly eat up your frame time.
The more time you're
spending doing GCs
the less time you have to do
other stuff like rendering
or streaming audio.
Now, a common issue that can
cause a cascade of GC events
to occur is a memory leak.
Memory leaks are objects
which the application
is no longer using.
But the garbage collector fails
to recognize them as unused.
The result is that they
stay resident in your heap,
taking up valuable space that's
never freed for other objects.
Now, as you start
leaking more memory,
the available space
in your heaps space
continues to get smaller.
Which means that
GCs will be executed
more often to try to free
up space for normal program
execution.
Which doesn't really work if
large portions of your heap
are never actually being freed.
Finding and fixing leaks
is really tricky business.
Now, effectively, you have
to have a clear understanding
of your code and be able
to validate that things
work the way they should during
critical actions in your code
base.
To confirm this
type of behavior,
however, requires
a bit of scrutiny.
Now, for example,
let's say you want
to ensure that
when a user leaves
an activity in your
application, that all
of the memory for that activity
is properly cleaned up.
How would you go
about doing this?
Well, firstly, you
should use the Heap tool
to grab a snapshot of
what memory looks like
while your activity
is front most.
And secondly, you need to
create some blank activity
with known or
low-memory allocations
that you can transition into
from the activity in question.
And thirdly, when you transition
from one to the other,
force a garbage
collection event to occur.
Which, if everything
is destroyed properly,
should remove all the
activities allocations.
If you see anything suspect
in that second heap dump, that
is memory that shouldn't
actually be there,
then it's a smart idea to switch
over to the Allocation Tracker
tool and dig a little
deeper with what
allocations are occurring.
Using this tool, you can
start tracking allocations
from before the activity
loads until it's unloaded
and you've transitioned it
back into the blank activity.
The allocation tracker
tool will give you
a list of all objects
that were created,
the order in which
they were created,
and where they were created.
So that you can track down
these types of rogue allocations
and figure out why they
aren't being freed.
Even though you're in a
managed memory environment,
you still have a lot of
manual memory management
to do yourself in order to
keep your app performant.
So make sure to check out
the rest of the resources
at Android Performance
Pattern Change.
And don't forget to check out
the Google+ community for other
great tips and tricks as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]